this is the story of a man and a woman
that man and woman they're about to take
a journey into the deepest darkest
depths of cinema all the way to the
stuntman's oh well guys this is the
much-hyped scary movie video that I've
been talking to you guys about this is
my fiancee Sam if you have not seen her
in videos before what we're gonna be
doing is taking you guys through a
journey of some of our favorite scary
films that we like to watch this time of
year it may not necessarily be the
cliched classic pics you're not gonna
see certain films on here if your
favorite film isn't on here we apologize
this is just kind of our list of things
we like to watch this season a scary
time of year it's a lot of fun slightly
nostalgia factor 2 behind some of our
picks one of the things we have done for
you guys is we have filmed various skits
as well for your first certain films not
every film we talked about will have a
skit but we have about three or four for
you guys in this video I'm a total geek
and I love doing this kind of stuff and
it makes my holidays happier the first
time we're gonna be talking about is a
classic it's film from the 60s it is
black and white
and it is a film that many laud as one
of the best suspense films ever made
so please enjoy our skit
[Music]
well guys how did you enjoy that I made
my appearance quite known in this last
skit
yes nice shower scene that was fun to
film yeah but anyway Alfred Hitchcock's
Psycho is as I said a classic movie and
it's a movie that parts of it I will be
completely honest with you guys there
are certain aspects of it that are
slightly dated and that comes with the
territory it's like 53 years old yeah
from that perspective the film holds up
extremely well though and I think really
the character of Norman Bates is really
what makes this movie better than your
average serial killer esque movie
because it you don't think it's like
that as you're watching the film unless
you of course know of the various famous
twists and scenes for the original piece
that it is it did push the boundaries
one of many mouths yeah to agree with
what you're saying to me the movie
really starts when she arrives at the
Bates Motel to me that's when the movie
starts because up until then you're
getting to know her character you're
learning vital information about her
you're seeing that she wants to escape
and steal you know forty thousand
dollars but really once she has that
conversation with Norman Bates in that
room with the birds and all the
taxidermy that's where the movie really
starts to get creepy the addition of
Anthony Perkins as Norman Bates that
really propels that movie into something
great and of course the shower scene the
classic showers
present first a boy's best friend is his
mother opening titles back then were
always so long and they were just these
really long cross dissolving images of
like everyone in the movie ever and
psycho was one of the first movies to
really kind of revolutionize the way
opening credits were like they actually
they made opening credits sequences
opening credits sequences because back
then it was like it was for the credits
but psycho took the credits and since
the movie started with such intense
music and then got really slow-paced
after that because of that intense
opening you're like something is coming
in this movie like it's gonna get
intense at some point because that
opening credits makes you feel that way
my one problem with the entire movie is
the psychiatrist scene where he
basically explains everything to the
audience is it for idiots now nowadays
were more savvy as audience members
we've seen more twist endings we grow to
expect that type of thing in the 60s
though audiences were blown
way by that and I understand why they
use the big explanation scene but
nowadays it feels kind of like yeah I
get it I don't need you to explain this
to me a lot of the books that I read
that are dated before psycho came out in
the murder mystery genres they're
explicit and definitely very much
graphic but they do have to spell things
out for people a little bit more I've
know numerous amounts of books I've read
things are a little bit more cut and dry
telling people unless if you have to
figure it out yourself
but followed by it is the classic scene
where he's like I wouldn't even have to
fly and he looks at the scream of that
evil glare it's perfect just like go to
witch we're not gonna talk about so well
the next film we haven't filmed a skit
for but it's a film that for you and I I
think is it's more fun you know like
it's a scary film but it's also a fun
film and that is Sleepy Hollow Tim
Burton's Sleepy Hollow there's a lot of
adaptations of it that's my favorite one
and probably the best one it is
definitely the biggest budget one it's
one of the films that I think Johnny
Depp was truly great in because nowadays
it's like everything he does he's got
like white face paint on all he has no
face paint on and he's actually kind of
wearing period piece clothing that looks
like a normal human being and he's not a
pirate
he's not drunk he's not walking like an
idiot right okay his character does
faint a lot right funny quirks to his
character well it's definitely Johnny
Depp's style of acting it's very clichéd
in his great speeches his play off words
his quirky innuendos he throws into the
character and maybe just maybe making it
his own kind of personality in there too
it's really a Tim Burton movie for sure
and it's perfect ability for him there's
so much Gothic imagery in the film lots
of dark forests and mists all over the
place there's witches and all kinds of
things it's it's really a perfectly for
him it was actually kind of a shock to
see a scene in white at the end yeah
you're like oh wait wait color color
it's white it's not great there's snow
and white buildings and people in white
clothing for me this movie is cool
because not just the Headless Horseman
and the fight scenes in the action
scenes but there's actually a pretty
kind of dark and disturbing backstory to
Ichabod cranes you
in this movie where you know he
witnessed certain things happen with his
mother
scars on his hands for that reason this
movie kind of goes a little bit beyond
just the fun
spooky type of movie that it is it's
just a fun adventure type movie set back
in 1799 as a revenge piece - if you
really stop to think Lee it's a revenge
beat all across the board definitely a
revenge piece Christopher Walken as the
Headless Horseman is pretty entertaining
for myself the next things we're gonna
be talking about we're actually gonna
bunch two things into one category
because one of the things we wanted to
do is not just present a whole bunch of
horror films that you know for eighteen
plus we wanted to talk about some films
that your entire family can enjoy as
well this time of year the first thing
we want to talk about is not a film it
is a TV special and that is Charlie
Brown in the great pumpkin to me this is
extremely important this time of year
because it's Charlie Brown and the Great
Pumpkin yeah that's what's called I love
Charlie Brown I've grown up with him I
have some of the original comic strips
back behind me actually in this
bookshelf they've been in all of my
reviews you guys I've always left Snoopy
I watched the TV show when I was a kid
I've read the comic strips I was really
sad when Charles Schulz died and I
wasn't gonna be able to see an original
peanuts comic
every Sunday in the paper yeah it's
definitely one of those pieces I look
forward to watching every fall I love
Charlie Brown and Snoopy and Woodstock
which is surprising I had an entire
collection of Woodstock did you yeah I
loved Woodstock Woodstock is awesome but
if you guys want to watch something that
your entire family can watch it's only
like 26 or 27 minutes long it's a lot of
fun for the whole family it's got a
message in there kind of it's but it's
just it's enjoyable it's freaking
peanuts you if you don't like Snoopy I
don't understand you I don't I'm sorry
it makes you feel warm you want to wrap
up in a blanket and watch Charlie Brown
there be
and that's just where that that's the
best place that this television think
exists right so the next thing we're
going to talk about is also kind of a
children ask like thing but since it was
on in the 90s most of the kids who are
now adults really like it still and that
is the goosebumps TV show this show it's
so dumb it really is like I've watched
almost all of it on Netflix there are so
many dumb moments the same type of
things happen in every episode where
like the first scare is usually a joke
oh no what's happening but it was just
all a big joke they're certain like
hitpoint cliches throughout the
Goosebumps show but it is so nostalgic
for me because i have a ton of
Goosebumps books right behind me I've
got a goosebumps poster right there I
have a lot of the movies still on my VHS
tape which I will from time to time pop
into a VCR don't judge me there's a
couple episodes of goosebumps I remember
really going it's gonna happen what's
been happy even though I know I read the
book I read the book I still always
wondered what direction they were
actually gonna take that episode in
because sometimes they were just a
little a little bit different than the
book I know you tell me what your
favorite episode was and that was
vampire breath for some reason I always
vividly remember that episode asked the
two kids doing what they're told not to
do go to exploring around the house they
head into a crypt that just magically
opens in their basement run into a
little girl yep supposedly trapped been
trapped in that sewer system for god
knows how long and then run into an old
man then turns around and completely
goes from me and I'm getting chased and
about to get killed by a vampire to them
being vampires and the room father
finding his fangs and getting his
vampire breath back just like it's
pretty awesome
that's goosebumps see like they did
stuff like that like oh the kids are
gonna go in the basement and go on a
John adventure because that's how I kind
of was as a kid when I was a kid I would
always go outside and use my imagination
quite a bit like I would be in all kinds
of areas when I would take walks in the
forest when I was in my mind but in my
mind yeah I wasn't actually doing
anything wrong so goosebumps to me was
that when I was a kid I used to read all
the books I was obsessed with the covers
of the books because I always got the
covers and be like Oh giant praying
mantids my favorite episode of the show
is the werewolf a fever swamp part one
into I watched that so many times as a
kid my mom and I used to pop that in and
we'd have like a Friday night dinner or
something and we were watched Ted I'm
not even kidding it was just a lot of
fun for me and I've always enjoyed that
show and I still enjoy it today
episodes that are really good for this
time here are attack of the
jack-o'-lanterns the Haunted mask and
the Haunted mask - it's the thing for my
childhood and if you haven't checked it
out you probably won't enjoy it as much
if you didn't grow up with it but for us
it's kind of fun the next film on our
list is probably the newest film that
we're gonna be talking to you guys about
and we have prepared a skit for you most
of the films we're gonna be talking
about are slightly older and this is one
that came out that I personally really
enjoyed that I think is going to become
something that people like to watch year
to year so please enjoy our skit
[Music]
insidious James Wan directed this film
on a budget of 1.5 million dollars and
it made like 70 million dollars for
something worldwide which is a crazy
crazy profit and the sequel he made for
just a little bit more it still made
quite a bit of profit that guy its
revenue possibly up James Wan is a
director who really understands how to
use his budget and one of the things I
loved about insidious was how practical
it was in regards to the effects there
isn't any flashy computer effects in
that movie barely at all there's maybe
like one or two very noticeable visual
effects shots for the most part the
movie is all makeup and prosthetics
dolls and stuff and that's one of the
things I that really bothered me of
having Sidious like the first time I saw
it it actually really disturbed me and
not just from a jump-scare factor I just
kind of gotten under my skin I have to
say is actually one of the few films
that actually I was kind of freaked out
when things popped out really and
usually I can sit through a film going
well it's just right but it's one of
those films were you don't know you just
don't know if it's gonna turn around
there shouldn't be something there so it
actually did catch me off guard in a
couple places where I was just like what
was that I think were the best examples
of that is when the families sitting
around the dinner table and the mother
tells this story about a dream that she
had where she goes inside Dalton's room
and in there is that creature and points
at Dalton then all of a sudden it's just
standing behind Patrick Wilson to me the
first time I saw it in theaters also
such a freaky looking face it's like
Darth Maul from Phantom Menace
definitely one of those films that you
will catch yourself off a guard most
scary films don't scare me and if you
can actually get a surprise out of me
good job cuz I don't get scared very
easily for me insidious just has this
very creepy tone to it that I think is
just absolutely perfect for October it
is the kind of movie that I can watch
year-round and still enjoy but for some
reason it just feels like the perfect
October movie by the way the composer of
the score is actually the guy who plays
the the demon creature know if you knew
that he actually did all the makeup
himself and everything was pretty cool
actually the way they did that
but I didn't know yeah all right guys
the next film we are introducing to you
is the shining one of the films I
actually just had a chance to watch
again I haven't seen it in years and I
actually completely forgot what was in
it and I was like it's such a
suspenseful film it gets under your skin
in a couple places this really does
Stanley Kubrick as a director was
notoriously particular about the way he
shot his films he made Jack Nicholson do
the famous here's Johnny take I think
the number is almost 200 I'm not
entirely sure I think it was like 170
something he put his actors really
through the ringer especially Shelley
Duvall in the movie if you watch the
making of The Shining she hated working
on that movie and you can really see it
in her performance too and I think
that's what Stanley Kubrick was trying
to do because what I heard was that he
gave Jack Nicholson like every leeway
possible and he was just odd Shelley
Duvall all the time and I think what he
was trying to do was actually make Jack
Nicholson and Shelley Duvall at odds so
that their performance would actually
show that because that's what the movie
is really all about is once they get in
that hotel and it starts to affect him
as a couple they start to go farther and
farther apart but oh my god the
cinematographer in that movie is
immaculate it's one of the best friend
movies I've ever seen I've seen the
movie like three times but when I was
watching it with her again I was pinned
to my seat like I'm not even kidding I
was just it's so well done I have to say
I don't know how the kid did not win an
award for his act one of the best actors
in the entire film he really did a great
job and that is saying a lot for me
because I have a bit of a pet peeve with
child actors sometimes he did such a
good job in this movie the scene where
he's on this three wheeler and sees the
two twins that famous scene in the
hallway the reaction on his face it was
just he did such a great job in that
movie his voice his face and everything
he was just it was spot-on for what the
film needed from how the book was to the
movie it's kind of not the same usually
disappointed by that thing but I'm
actually still happy with this film even
though it's not like the book it's one
of the few adaptations of Stephen King's
work that he is not pleased with
actually and it's funny because it might
be the best that
Shawshank Redemption or maybe the best
film adaptations in my opinion of his
books I understand though why he said
because like you said it does straight
from the novel but the thing about The
Shining to me but let's just forget
about the great cinematography the great
performance by Jack Nicholson the iconic
great performance by Jack Nicholson it's
the feel and tone of the movie because
even from the beginning of the film you
get like this odd sense that just off
and if you watch the documentary room
237 which I got a chance to see this
year I didn't get a chance to review
that but it's all about the making of
the shining and people's theories about
the whole moon landing and everything
which is really interesting if you guys
have not checked that out it was a very
good documentary the thing that Stanley
Kubrick was trying to create from the
beginning of that movie was an extreme
sense of unease where you just felt like
this isn't right like everything just
feels not right and it gets all the way
to the end of the movie where you see
the guy in a bear costume giving a
blowjob to the guy in the bed you're
like what that's one of the biggest WTF
moments in movies of all time but then
you learned that there were costume
parties there and you're like what she
was seeing a ghost of something that
happen in the past the drive up the
mountain is disturbing the actual hotel
when you first walk in is disturbing the
way the staff acts is almost kind of on
a disturbing level it's just every bit
of the film puts you in that age right
just makes you on edge misfits alright
sorry Rob very scary very disturbing and
it's also a film that film enthusiasts
can really enjoy because it's a type of
movie that people who are into directing
or cinematography or writing you can
watch that movie and you can just
examine the hell out of it I remember
sitting and watching it and going oh
this room isn't done in just like
primaries everything every bit of this
film if you stop and if she's watch it
is primary color or primary color or if
it's not a primary color it's pretty
much just the whole room is that color
with just little bits and accents of
other colors and just means for a
beautiful shot because there's your
visually more interested in the
characters the stuff in the background
is kind of fades into that one color so
all you see are the people in the action
going on in front of that color I think
the Red Room where the Blue Room in the
green room with gold
that's all you see the last one we're
gonna be talking about is another film
that we have prepared a skit for you for
this is a film from the 90s it's a film
that kind of parodied the horror genre a
little bit it's a little meta and it's
got a lot of good in jokes in there but
it's also a pretty entertaining movie so
please enjoy our skit
[Music]
hello what's your favorite scary movie
what are you doing tonight honey that's
wide the living hell would you watch
that movie these days so anyways I was
saying what's your favorite scary movie
you ever mention that come again I'll
cut your throat you little bitch no this
isn't Chris this is the day that's gonna
take a knife and spread your insides all
over your kitchen speaking of your
kitchen you shouldn't leave your
microwave door
[Music]
you know marks I really know her she's a
mess you might be dating my best friend
but this doesn't give you the right to
be an asshole at me like so 1984 Terry
boys are trying to pull that little
bitch made me think of Dragonball
Evolution she's going to do a scream
directed by Wes Craven this movie came
out in 1996 and a lot of people look at
this movie when it first came out and
we're thinking okay it's another slasher
horror film and it has all that in there
but it also has a great sense of making
fun of it but not in like the the scary
movie sense where it's just some giant
spoof it just had all of the different
tropes that horror films always have
where oh you don't want to have sex
because then you're gonna die it makes
fun of the cliches one of my favorite
lines in the movie is my Neve Campbell
is on the phone and she's like if I was
in one of those movies I couldn't act
and I'd have big old boobs and it was
just like yeah that's a pretty much how
most of them go nowadays and that's one
of the things that I really liked about
scream because I have seen quite a bit
of terrible horror films in fact I'm
gonna be talking you guys about some of
those in a couple days here I'm gonna be
doing a video on the worst horror
remakes and sequels and I have been re
watching some of them so that I can
prepare and Wow there really are some
terrible ones and scream pokes fun at a
lot of them in the best types of ways
because it's actually able to present a
pretty entertaining movie as well
because like the entire finale is like
30 35 minutes long in this one house and
I really enjoyed it like I was actually
on edge and getting into it even though
I've seen it before I watched it again
about a week ago to prepare but it's not
just the fact of the movie as I said is
a fun film that makes you go yeah that's
pretty much how all these stupid horror
movies are it does have a good sense of
actual horror in it as well
does because there's body counts pretty
high once you have to start to think
about it definitely that classic opening
what you're very mark have you yourself
parodied very well yeah so guys that is
part one of our scary movie special
there I'm sure some films you're like
why did he talk about those films they
may be in part two or maybe we're not
going to talk about them at all I
apologize if your favorite films aren't
on our list also thank you very much for
submitting footage to the Ring skit that
will be in part two you guys have
submitted some really cool footage and
I'm looking forward to sharing that with
you guys and that's gonna be up on
Sunday and thanks Sam for being this
video with me and I appreciate that as
well you're a good person she's a good
person
thanks very much for watching and as
always if you liked this you can click
right there
and I do want to go get some d pumpkin
pie excuse me let's go get some longer
pie
oh okay so I used to go make a pumpkin
yeah I think I said it over there
brother window can you check
[Music]
hey huh
who's that
there's a guy out there
[Music]
what do you think he wants I think he
wants to be in part too
[Music]
you